e da tutti ragazzi e benvenuto nel suo
video sono famiglie ed oggi siamo su una
nuova reaction su delle cose che fanno
su di me fa chi è sempre vj fosse una
donna photoshop makeover trasformazione
da uomo donna fa vj mai cosa sto per
vedere ragazzi questo video a scopo di
intrattenimento ma guarda ci mancherebbe
che bella donna
ciao a tutti questo secondo makeover che
riguarda il cambiamento di genere degli
youtube per gli italiani la scorsa
puntata è stata infatti dedicata smith
ex che ha persino ha commentato base di
tex è già una donna non mi sembra la
voce di sottofondo che mettono nei
documentari quando fanno tipo in tv lina
klina blur
ma che grazie se non avete ancora visto
quel video vi lascio il link
indiscrezioni teresa lease back basta
sparma visita è servita questa
affascinante con il mio dio
ma cosa cazzo è questo il ragazzo stai
facendo zia il protagonista di oggi lo
avete scelto voi attraverso i commenti
che culo grande grazie che mi fa vedere
con me no voglio vedere fammi vedere con
i trasformi basta interessa
parlerò zio di farvi cei il naso la mia
prima mano con più iscritti
devo fare questa precisazione perchè
live italiana più famosa è tecnicamente
chieti poi marzia se però si rivolge ad
un pubblico straniero
vabbè dedica un documentario l'abbia sta
parlando di informazioni non sta
trasformando le cercherà voi cosa vi è
anche player ma personalmente non lo sai
cooper i format che lo hanno reso famoso
grazie a essi tvblog ha operato male
quindi blaye les mines lavorative
figurano anche un ruolo di attore nel
film che inter p quello di doppiatori
ratchet and clank la pubblicazione di un
album di figurine e del libro sotto le
cuffie raga un sacco di cose non ne
sapevo neanche io che faceva i
documentari su linea blu google che da
un su rai tre e poi visto che parlava di
pesci ha detto facciamo trasformazioni
uomo donna degli youtube
questo è quello che comunque non so se
ve ne siete accorti ma nel frattempo io
sono diventato alien alien che questo
video non ha nessuno scopo offensivo o
denigratorio
non so se sarò così fortunata da far
arrivare questo filmato all'attenzione
di favi j
se cosi alta eventuali suoi fan che
captano sul mio canale ma sarà gianni
pali dello sgombro che vive nel
mediterraneo adesso grazie
chi è questa nel caso e suggeriti mickey
vorrei vilardi ragazzo modello dovrà
esercitare ulteriormente per riuscire a
me va bene così via
oddio sembro mia madre protesta papa
quei basta ritagliare donne
particolarmente complessa infatti ha
dovuto rifarlo daccapo
scegliendo un'altra immagine ma che una
foto con le caratteristiche adatte a
questo genere di lavoro grafico
adesso sì che possono fare il
protagonista di frode ma cosa cazzo sto
guardando regala cos'è film con the
white musk ha potuto alle emozioni non
mi chiamerà in anche col pene di un
altro ci sentiamo alla fine per i saluti
grazie va bene ciao ci vediamo dopo
ragazzi io non credo di aver mai visto
niente ma neanche paragonabile
lontanamente a questo c'è come io devo
mandare sta roba mia madre io vanti di
gesù dio che faccio la foto la mando a
mia madre faceva reaction chiara per un
po ci somiglia non è un alieno mia mamma
a differenza di questi questa immagine
però però però ragazzi che cosa cazzo
stop ed è c'erano mai visto la rosetta
c'e nella mia vita non avrei mai pensato
di poter vedere una roba del per cos'è
ma ma michael jackson per basta che le
labbra zia però di voi così male
il lipstick forca h
ma cosa sono cose
sono più apprezzabile come donna da
maschio che devi da donne che non sono
appena visto la venezia salutami quale
youtuber vorreste vedere donna delhi
mello file del livello tra il cemento
numero insolitamente alto di richieste
ma chissà perché si sa se avete
apprezzato i contenuti lasciato sei
questa faccio lucas se più bella di me
dawn ma perché ci vuole poco per sé
molto carina ragazzo c'è anche esterni
grazie a dio ci hanno fatto anche il
tecnico si io non guardo solo me stesso
perché sono mica che figura di merda
sestetto ni è più bello di me donna vi
ammazzo tra contenta la marina mi guardo
anche questo poiché grazie veramente
sono veramente una [ __ ] il rimorchio che
o studia cere questo è il terzo makeover
della playlist dedicata ai cambiamenti
di cenere degli youtuber italiani come
fai a farlo solo degli occhiali zia
impossibile lui appare talvolta nei blog
di favi jane e fa parte di una forza
come qualcosa
la mia vita ha parlato di blog e per
step mi ha detto che ad ogni tanto
appare nei miei video così quella il
ruolo gli stemmi niente appare nei video
di poi gen basta traghettato mista in
jeans
ai presidi e non fare da per certo
grazie a cazzo se di tagli e mattone
verna mai più bello lui questa questo
favoritismo c'è la guardava bene set
sembra un po la mia ex
none marozzo non aspetta aspetta spero
che ci stai confronto che aspetta
aspetta allora ragazzi quasi sfida qua
c'è assolutamente sfida saranno
decisamente più gnocca io [ __ ]
stefano cos'è santo gesù soprattutto per
le serie faccio faccio riguardo
direttamente alla fine i tre ci siete o
mio dio sei bellissima salvo salva
salvatore fatemi delle anima e poi con
chiudiamo perché non c'ha molto più fare
oggi superati ma anche per una gnocca
seria ecco che le bocce bravo sasha
secondo me tra tra tutti
sasha vince secondo yo yo yo yo potevi
vedere finita in mano la curiosità è
uguale ma è infatti riguardo va bene
ragazzi dire che dopo questo possono
chiudere qui perché troppo da un mi
ricordo l'ultima volta che ho fatto
video così trash i ragazzi spero che
video vi sia piaciuto che cosa sarebbe
servito il momento non mi piace ha anche
i vari social che come di ridotto da
nell'edizione e noi ci vediamo al
prossimo video bene ragazzi che sono
ancora uomo uomo ancora no perché mi
cresce la barba mezzo uomo da ragazzi
ecco la mia madre che arriva la risposta
mi ha scritto chi è ma come chi è
sono io donna non sembri però io gli ho
scritto ti piaccio papa dice che
assomiglia a metà giovane ma ho detta
l'avevo detto io che ci somigliamo un po
mia madre
[Musica]